what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch two
new trailers for Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania you know how we do when our
movies coming around the corner ladies
and gentlemen leave a like for John
that's the only reason you'll leave a
like so you better go ahead and do it
right John that's right you like me you
really like me
also guys I will not stop plugging these
shirts until the movie's on and maybe
even after depending on the reception of
the film Citizen Kane shirts people real
rejects exclusive I want to thank
everyone who has already bought
themselves a shirt from
shopzeroedition.com because it's one of
the best ways to support the channel and
it's just
b-i-t-c-h-i-n I forget the YouTube rules
about swear words in the beginning of a
video I love wearing them get
compliments on them at the gym and I go
I don't know like what I'm like
just go away go away don't talk to me
anymore vocal cords
hate when hot women at the gym talk to
me it's really uncomfortable alrighty
let's get to it guys
oh we're gonna watch uh the new Dynasty
spot and the featurette drop them in a
final cut I think the featurettes first
but we're just gonna watch it in one go
then we'll talk about whatever's in here
[Music]
we always love doing the unexpected with
Scott Lang Batman is arguably the
character that is the most
underestimated and underrated a key to
saving the universe in Avengers end game
yeah so carrying that tradition we
thought well let's use this film to kick
off phase five that's really cool in
almost a decade now that I've been
playing this part I've loved it and I
feel protective of Scott Lang and
Ant-Man it's really nice coming back I
still kind of can't believe that I'm
sitting there and it's like wow there's
Michelle Pfeiffer and there's Michael
Douglas I just saved eight bucks gotta
admire you
that's not to get used to working with
Legends sure you're sending a signal
down to the quantum Realm
[Applause]
where wow the quantum realm Universe
beneath ours Janet has been very quiet
about her time in the quantum realm
maybe would have made different choices
cool Jesus isn't what you think
different choices with Kang it's
terrifying and if there ever was a
maniac loose in the quantum realm it's
him
playing Kang the Conqueror is such a
gift your reality
you're holding on to I know how it is
this is the beginning and he cannot be
contained he's the beginning and the end
that shot man always gets something like
this which is so transportive and
visually striking people should really
see it in a movie theater
yes you want it to be as big and as
visceral and consuming as possible
audiences are going to watch this and go
I can't believe this is happening it's
going to be Bonkers I hope I have that
response we're camping we've never been
camping but we've always talked about it
that's what he's fighting for to go
camping
Scotland
you're an Avenger oh
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time she's a
troublemaker
I'm the man who can give you
time
Scott you cannot trust him
I just lost so much he can give us a
second chance ooh good trailer
he will bring me what I need
everything you call a life will end
you've may not want her to watch this I
had a deal
you thought you could win I don't have
to win we both just have to lose
sorry Cassie that man in the WASP
Quantum yeah
it's like overwhelming
oh my goodness gorgeous and glorious is
how I feel when watching that trailer
both of those trailers you know I feel
like these featurettes sometimes just
don't get enough respect and they often
do a good job of reminding me of where
we're coming from because you know
looking back on uh the first Ant-Man
film and even the second especially the
second one the way that was received a
film that I was like I actually quite
enjoyed this one but I got I got a lot
of crap
the place where it was slotted to have
this be the kick off for phase five and
for ant-man's its third film a movie The
ironic sense of like this the tiniest
character in all of the MCU to get one
of this this like massive debut and to
be part of like this massive Trilogy on
an endnote because I've always been sort
of on the smaller side
now they're gonna be even smaller but
also even bigger but you know what I
mean guys I've always been a little bit
more on on the less scale side you know
like sometimes consequential sometimes
we're slotted in between films that had
like the biggest Stakes ever and then
they get a film that's not that big
mistakes comparatively to what we just
saw so to get a movie where it's going
to be uh an introduction and a
definition for what phase five is going
to ultimately uh amount to and to have
King the Conqueror be introduced in here
I think that's just so cool for for this
specific franchise because especially
with Ant-Man when you look at it they've
had the same cast other than Michelle
Pfeiffer came in the second one and then
Cassie Langston
but they've had the same main core
players and the director uh from the
beginning you know if you exclude the
whole thing
yes but but they've had the same thing
essential Parts yeah I'm talking
Evangeline Lily and Michael Douglas is
all right and and uh what is his name
it's not Scott Derrickson who's the guy
who directed this movie
and to have Peyton Reed uh helming it
and to have this journey I feel like
ant-man's earned it uh to be here and
yeah and I and the second trailer too
was great because it it focused I said a
lot John you you say some stuff
yeah I I liked that they highlighted it
I think what one thing that hasn't
really fully hit me but I think is
really cool is here they highlighted how
like Scott Lang was crucial instrumental
in the outcome of end game which is like
the Pinnacle and we're going into phase
five it's been a whole phase since then
but two this does feel like very
consequential and like there is
something culminating here and so to
have this sort of uh opposite bookend
with Scott Lang yeah helping through the
quantum realm save everybody's bacon on
the last Go Round And now here he's
going into the quantum realm to
potentially you know we'll see how it
goes but maybe make the ultimate
sacrifice and maybe a similarly heroic
thing but with an opposite kind of an
outcome or a heavier sort of outcome and
so yeah like I think it's a nice full
circle moment for uh the character and
two I mean yeah I think we both are sort
of in the minority of people who both
really liked Ant-Man and the wasp and
the first one too I've always found very
charming and here this feels like yeah
this is going to be the one that
elevates the character to a bigger
caliber in terms of the weight and the
impact because I mean looking at the
full second trailer and then this TV
spot I just love the amount of like
intensity and stakes and I think for
this character that's a cool thing
because that's not been what they've LED
with up until now so not only do we get
sort of a Twist on the tone in you know
the micro Universe of just Ant-Man but
also now yeah this big important
contribution to the you know entirety of
phase five and six to come yeah with the
scope and the scale to have it be on
this visually daring and psychedelic of
a level I think is really cool it feels
natural for Ant-Man at the same time
because you know we've teased the
quantum realm via through Ant-Man yeah
even with endgame that's how we get
there so to have it be like all within
here it doesn't feel like an unnatural
transition to suddenly do something this
high stakes and this High Caliber this
High concept of visuals because it's
been leading to this the entire time and
I think it's really neat it's kind of
it's kind of a unique array into the
franchise it's sort of like the opposite
of what happened with Thor which was a
lot more heavy and gravitas that became
a joke this was like more jokey and then
now it's become like this heavy bigger
serious epic and it's pretty cool to see
how it's it's naturally got in there and
still feels like it and and it does
worry about the characters and I'm
excited for Cassie Lang because it
seemed like yeah this would be the heart
of the movie is how much he wants time
back you would be willing to work with
King and make such a Desperate Measures
call yeah for something that is clearly
not the smart move because it's preying
on some so Primal for him and it would
be this the selfish choice that you
would be so tempted to make yeah yeah
man Hero's making selfish choices that
is a big part of MCU characters damn you
Star-Lord we could have gotten rid of
Thanos sooner I'm still mad about it
that's all you had to do never got over
it guys are you excited for Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania do you already have
your tickets what are you hoping happens
in the end did you read the script
leaked I haven't read it yet it's kind
of hard to find now
[Music]
Luis gonna be in it that's all I want to
know that's all I want to know tell me
all right guys
we got ourselves a new Patron his name
is Garth Garth ooh Garth McMurray party
on Garth you're gonna get a traditional
shout out in the form of G stands for G
willikers Dre only bad syllables ah a
stands for ant Ant-Man cause you're on
the Ant-Man video R stands for rodeo
clowns are disturbing T stands for you
are titanium
H stands for Heathen yeah yeah you
filthy you're a heathen Garth yeah
anyway Garth I hope we uh nailed the
shout out in the way that you were
hoping to I think we did a little bit
more than we were required for out of
the park into the next County I'm happy
that we were able to fulfill our duties
our obligations in order to make you a
happy camper and making you a happy
camper just makes me a mediocre camper
so thank you Garth for being part of a
patreon page and showing the support you
have graduated from a citizen of the
reject Nation to a super sexy citizen
region there's a lot of work
[Music]